Alright guys, so here is example number two. So basically there are some other things that I want to throw it out. So when you are extremely bullish or bearish, you know, every auto block or I would say, demand zone could be, you know, a POI. And you can look for confirmation entries from those POIs. So for example, right here, you can see we are bullish right here. I'm looking at GVPUSD.
And there is this auto block right here.
Right?
And the thing that I was talking about
how to combine DXY with the Australian strategy.
So when you have a institutional support level
or auto block here and price comes back
into this auto block, when price comes back
this autoblog on GPPUSD, you go to DXY and see if price is also at the resistance
level of some sort. So as you know, the DXY chart is inverse to this. So if the
as we used is going up, DXY is gonna go down.
Simple, right?
But around here, when price reaches this autoblock
and on DXY, price at the same time, okay?
Not at the same time, but if it's at the resistance level,
right, let's assume that this is DXY
and this is autoblock, and price is here
at the autoblock and also on GPPUSD prices
at the support level or bullish autoblock, right?
Then that is a confluence that you can use.
So in other words, in simple words,
uh, zbp-USD-USD-Audz. If they are at some OB and at this if one of these are at some
OB and at the same time dxy is at some OB as well. So OB could be a resistance or support
level. So generally auto blocks are supported resistance levels. Okay. So that's why I'm calling
them support and resistance. So let's assume that GVP and your USD both of them hit the
autoblock right here. Okay. Or I would say that GPP USD hits the autoblock. Your
USD does not hit the autoblock and DXY also is at some sort of resistance level. Right.
Then you should trade GPP USD. If your USD hits the autoblock right and GPP USD and
AUDU SD do not hit the auto block, which is right here, do not touch the auto block.
And at the same time, DXY is at the resistance level.
It is touching the resistance or an auto block here, which could be actually this, my
bad.
Right?
Then you want to trade your USD.
I know this is sounding a little bit complicated, but it is not.
If you really focus on that, what I'm trying to say.
And let's say the GBUSD and the USB both are not touching the auto block and they are
somewhere around here, right?
And aUDUSD has already touched this auto block and at the same time DXY is also at some sort
of resistance level.
Then that my friend is the sign that you should be trading aUDUSD.
I hope that is clear guys.
So let me show you how this works.
So we know that we are bullish, right?
Price going up.
We have this auto block right here.
So I dropped down to 15 minute time from.
Look for a shift in market structure.
There you go.
We have a market structure shift.
And this right here.
OK, so here's another thing.
On the photo time for when you're looking
to identify your POI, you should mark out
consecutive bearish candles.
Okay, most of the time,
it's like so many bearish candles, right?
Just mark out the last candle,
or the one above it, from above it.
Okay, but when you are looking for entries on 15 minutes,
you should always take your entry
from the very last bearish candle
before the multi-ups are that broke the structure.
So let's wait for price to come back
into our PIO, into our entry zone, kaboom.
That is our entry during London session.
So that is a plus point.
Put our stop right below this level.
Target one to two, and I go back home.
And there you go, perfect, perfect move.
But you can see, you can hold, it really depends on.
You guys, I only look for one to two, as I've said before,
in my videos multiple times.
So, yeah guys, I hope you guys understood what I tried to teach.
If you did not, feel free to ask questions and I'll try to answer them in my discord server.